REMEMBER I’M WATTERS AND THIS IS
MY WORLD.
[♪]
JUDGE JEANINE: WELCOME TO
"JUSTICE," I’M JUDGE JEANINE
PIRRO.
YES, THE RUMORS ARE TRUE.
WE DID IT AGAIN LAST WEEKEND.
"JUSTICE" WAS NUMBER ONE ALL
WEEKEND, SATURDAY, SATURDAY
NIGHT, SUNDAY AND SUNDAY NIGHT.
TONIGHT THE ODDS ARE IN OUR
FAVOR AGAIN.
I HAVE SENATE JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN
LINDSEY GRAHAM, COREY
LEWANDOWSKI, DARRELL ISSA,
CHARLIE KIRK, ALL WITH ME LIVE.
BUT FIRST MY OPEN.
THIS WEEK WE WITNESSED THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A LEADER AND
A WANNABE.
THE STARK CONTRAST BETWEEN
SOMEONE WHO IS A WORLD LEADER
AND SOMEONE HOPING HIS DAY WILL
COME.
BUT BEING A LEADER TAKES VISION
AND FORTITUDE AND PERSISTENCE, A
DUG-IN DETERMINATION TO A GOAL
THAT NEVER CHANGES.
BY WAY OF EXAMPLE, PERMIT ME TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO A NON-LEADER.
THE FIRST UNITED STATES SENATOR
IN AMERICAN HISTORY TO VOTE TO
CONVICT THE PRESIDENT OF HIS OWN
PARTY, MITT ROMNEY.
THE SOLE AND ONLY REPUBLICAN TO
VOTE TO CONVICT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HOW DARE HE?
HOW COULD HE?
AND WHY WOULD HE?
MITT DARED TO DO WHAT HE THOUGHT
WAS GOOD FOR HIM INDIVIDUALLY.
NOT FOR THE PARTY, NOT FOR US,
AND CERTAINLY NOT FOR AMERICA.
HE KNEW HIS VOTE WOULD CHANGE
NOTHING REGARDING IMPEACHMENT.
BUT HE TRIED TO SET HIMSELF UP
AS THE LEADER GOING AGAINST
EVERYONE ELSE.
HE TOOK A STAND HE THOUGHT WOULD
IMPRESS OTHERS.
IT DID.
MANY ON THE LOONEY LEFT DEFENDED
HIM SAYING HIS VOTE WAS VERY
PATRIOTIC.
YES, HE ENDEARED HIMSELF TO THE
TRUMP-HATING LEFT, THE RADICALS
NOT INTERESTED IN THE AMERICA
FIRST AGENDA.
THOSE ALL ABOUT POWER NOT TRUTH.
SO WHY?
MITT SAYS HIS STRONG FAITH IS
THE REASON AND THAT GOD DEMANDED
IT OF ME.
>> MY PROMISE BEFORE GOD TO
APPLY IMPARTIAL JUSTICE REQUIRED
THAT I PUT MY PERSONAL FEELING
AND POLITICAL BIASES ASIDE.
WERE I TO IGNORE THE EVIDENCE
THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED AND
DISREGARD WHAT I BELIEVE MY OATH
AND THE CONSTITUTION DEMANDS OF
ME FOR THE SAKE OF A PARTISAN
END, IT WOULD, I FEAR, EXPOSE MY
CHARACTER TO HISTORY’S REBUKE.
JUDGE JEANINE: I’M CATHOLIC, I
WENT TO CATHOLIC SCHOOLS AND I
BELIEVE IN GOD.
DO YOU EVER WONDER WHEN PEOPLE
WHO NEVER MENTION GOD OR
RELIGION NEVER BRING IT UP UNTIL
THEY GET CAUGHT DOING SOMETHING
OR NEED AN EXCUSE PORK SOMETHING
THEY DID.
KIND OF LIKE NANCY PELOSI WHO
SO HATES DONALD TRUMP, ALMOST
HAS A CONNIPTION.
WHAT A BUNCH OF PHONEYS.
I CAN’T WAIT TO HEAR WHAT THEY
ARE GOING TO TELL ST. PETER WHEN
THEY GET THERE.
BUT LET ME MOVE ON FROM HIS
RELIGIOUS TO HIS SECULAR REASON.
>> I SOUGHT TO HEAR TESTIMONY
FROM JOHN BOLTON NOT ONLY
BECAUSE I BELIEVED HE COULDED A
CONTEXT TO THE CHARGES.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE I HOPED WHAT HE
MIGHT SAY COULD RAISE REASONABLE
DOUBT?
JUDGE JEANINE: THE TRANSCRIPT OF
THE TELEPHONE CALL WHICH NO ONE
EXPECTED THE PRESIDENT WOULD
RELEASE IS THE CORPUS.
IT’S THE BODY OF THE ALLEGED
WRONG DOING.
ANYTHING BEFORE, AFTER, AROUND
IT IS IRRELEVANT AND MATERIAL.
WHAT WAS SAID IN THAT
CONVERSATION IS WHAT ACQUITS OR
CONVICTS THE PRESIDENT.
HE USED THAT AS AN EXCUSE TO
CONVICT WHEN YOU DON’T EVEN KNOW
WHAT HE’S GOING TO SAY AND THE
PROSECUTOR HAVEN’T MADE OUT A
PRIMA FACIA CASE.
DO YOU WONDER WHY THE HOUSE
MANAGERS DIDN’T SUBPOENA BOLTON?
THE PROSECUTION DOESN’T PRESENT
EVIDENCE THAT YOU WANT AND YOU
DON’T HAVE THE SLIGHTEST IDEA
WHAT THAT EVIDENCE MIGHT BE OR
WHETHER IT’S EVEN RELEVANT.
YOU WANT TO USE THAT NOTHING
BURGER TO CONVICT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES?
ARE YOU STUPID, TOO?
YOU TAKE NON-EVIDENCE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS REFUSE TO PRESENT AS A
REASON TO CONVICT THE PRESIDENT
IN AN ECONOMY THAT IS
UNPARALLELED WITH A MILITARY
WHOSE STRENGTH IS UNEE CALLED,
WITH A POPULATION WHERE 90% ARE
HAPPY WITH THEIR LIVES?
YOU LAELY ARE STUPID.
YOU USE THE PROSECUTOR’S
INABILITY TO MAKE A CASE AS A
REASON TO VOTE GUILTY.
THE FACTS BEFORE YOU MAKE IT
CLEAR THERE WAS NO PRESSURE, NO
DEMANDS, NO D -- NO UKRAINIAN
INVESTIGATION.
OUR PRESIDENT HAD AN OBLIGATION
TO INVESTIGATE CORRUPTION,
ESPECIALLY WHERE UNITED STATES
TAXPAYERS’ MONEY GOES TO FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
AND YOU SAY THIS IS THE MOST
DIFFICULT DECISION YOU EVER
MADE?
MITT, YOU ARE FULL OF IT.
AND SINCE YOU ARE SUCH A SCHOLAR
DID YOU EVER CONSIDER THE
PRESIDENT’S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS THAT WERE STRIPPED FROM
HIM IN THE STAR CHAMBER WHERE HE
WAS DENIED THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE?
THE TRUTH IS YOU SIMPLY DESPISE
DONALD TRUMP.
YOUR JEALOUSY OF THIS MAN IS A
CONSTANT RAGE BURNING WITHIN YOU
BECAUSE YOU CAN NEVER RISE TO
THE HEIGHT THAT HE HAS.
BECAUSE GUYS LIKE YOU FOLD LIKE
WOSSES.
YOU DON’T HAVE SELFLESSNESS OR
THE ABILITY TO THINK ABOUT
OTHERS AS DONALD TRUMP HAS
THOUGHT ABOUT MAKING AMERICA
FIRST.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU ARE PANE
EMBARRASSMENT.
YOUR REASON THAT YOU WON’T
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP IF HE’S THE
PARTY’S THEM KNEE.
YOU WORLDY WHAT YOU ARE TELL
YOUR GRANDCHILDREN, WHEN THEY
ASK WHY, GRANDPA DIDN’T YOU STOP
DONALD TRUMP.
MAYBE YOU BETTER WORRY ABOUT
WHEN THEY ASK ABOUT YOUR LOSS TO
BARACK OBAMA.
WILL YOU TELL THEM THAT YOU
CHOKED?
MITT, LOSERS CHOKED.
YOU CHOKED WHEN A CNN REPORTER
PUSHED BACK ON YOU AND YOU
FOLDED LIKE EVERY OTHER LOSER.
YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND WHAT YOU WILL
SAY TO THEM.
YOU JUST DID IT AGAIN.
YOU ARE THE REASON BARACK OBAMA
GOT FOUR MORE YEARS WITH AN
ECONOMY IN THE TANK, A CALIPHATE
THAT WAS GROWING, LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND MILITARY MORALE
IN THE GARBAGE.
YOU HAVEN’T ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO
HIDE THE REAL YOU.
IN FACT PEOPLE OF MASSACHUSETTS
VOTED AGAINST YOU.
IT WAS ONE OF THE WORST HOME
STATE LOSSES IN PRESIDENTIAL
HISTORY.
AND YOUR ARROGANCE?
AGAIN ON FULL DISPLAY.
>> I DO BELIEVE HE SHOULD BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
JUDGE JEANINE: REALLY, MITT?
HE SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE?
FOR WHAT?
SO YOU CAN TRY TO MAKE ANOTHER
MOVE FOR PRESIDENT?
I HAVE GOT NEWS FOR YOU.
YOU HAVE GOT NO MOVES LEFT.
AT YOUR REQUEST DONALD TRUMP
SUPPORTED YOU IN 2012 AND 2018
AND LIKE A SNAKE IN THE GRAWS
TURNED ON HIM.
I HAVE AN IDEA, YOU NEED TO BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
HOW ABOUT YOU GET THE HELL OUT
OF THE UNITED STATES SENATE
BECAUSE PEOPLE IN UTAH ARE
FURIOUS WITH YOU.
AND YOUR DREAM OF ENDEARING
YOURSELF TO THE TRUMP-HATING
LEFT IS A JOKE.
SO MITT, PACK YOUR BAGS.
TAKE SOME TIME OFF AND RIDE
AROUND WITH YOUR DOG ON THE ROOF
OF YOUR CAR LIKE YOU DID WHEN
YOU USED TO VACATION WITH YOUR
FAMILY.
AND DON’T FORGET, WHEN YOU LIE
WITH DOGS YOU GET FLEAS.
BUT THAT WILL NEVER BE AS BAD AS
THE STAIN YOU FORGED UPON
WHATEVER LEGACY YOU THINK YOU
HAVE.
THAT’S MY OPEN.
LET ME HEAR WHAT YOU THINK ON